>>> DO YOU GUYS REMEMBER
CHELSEA?
>> YOUR EX CHELSEA
>> YEAH.
>> I HAVEN'T THOUGHT ABOUT HER
IN A WHILE.
>> WHEN YOU GUYS BROKE UP, IT
WAS SUCH A RELIEF.
>> SHE WAS SUCH A NEGATIVE
PERSON.
>> A BAD PERSON.
>> WHENEVER SHE WOULD WALK INTO
A ROOM, IT WAS LIKE, I GUESS
THIS ROOM IS GOING TO SUCK A
LITTLE BIT.
>> I WOULD HAVE DAY TREATMENTS
OF HER BEING STEPD ON BY A
GIANT.
>> SHE WOULD ALWAYS HAVE FOOD ON
HER SHIRT LIKE A BABY.
>> LIKE DOES THIS FOOD BELONG IN
MY NOUGT OR ON MY SHIRT.
SHE STUNG.
SHE WAS STINKY.
>> EWW, CHELSEA.
WHY?
WHAT'S GOING ON WITH CHELSEA
>> WE GOT BACK TOGETHER.
>> YOU DID
>> AND SHE'S RIGHT HERE.
>> CHELSEA.
>> IT IS SO GOOD TO SEE YOU.
JOHN, WHAT THE HELL?
SO ARE YOU GUYS SERIOUS OR
CASUAL
>> JOHN JUST PROPOSED.
WEDDING IS IN JUNE.
>> LOVE IT
CAN'T WAIT TO MEET THE FAMILIAR.
>> YOU ALREADY DID
THEY'RE ON ZOOM.
>> WHAT'S UP, FAMILY
>> Y'ALL DON'T SEEM TOO HAPPY
WITH ME.
>> ANYONE TALKS CRAP ABOUT MY
DAUGHTER, I'LL HUNT YOU DOWN --
>> TURN THAT OFF
YOU REMEMBER THAT STUFF WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT EARLIER?
>> I DO.
>> WE WERE TALKING ABOUT JOHN'S
OTHER EX COURTNEY.
>> COURTNEY WAS THE ONE WHO WAS
LIKE A FUGLY NERD.
>> WOW.
>> COURTNEY, DIDN'T SEE YOU.
>> WE DIDN'T MEAN TO INSULT YOU.
>> READ BACK THE WORDS.
>> SHE WAS LIKE A SLOPPY SEWER
SCUM.
>> GET OUT OF HERE YOU WEIRDO.
>> DON'T TALK ABOUT HER THAT
WAY.
SHE'S MY WIFE.
>> STEVE, COME ON.
YOU'RE OUR FAVORITE HOST.
>> FAVORITE HOST
>> DAMN IT
>> I'M TELLING MICHAEL CHE.
>> COME ON, GUYS
WHAT DID I TELL YOU ABOUT THE
RULES?
>> A, B, C RULE.
>> YEAH.
ALWAYS BE KIND
YOU BROKE THE RULES.
BEN'S THE ONE WHO STARTED THIS.
>> CAN YOU NOT TALK ABOUT BEN
THAT WAY
HE'S RIGHT HERE.
>> THAT'S REALLY NOT COOL, MAN.
>> COME ON, EVERYBODY.
MARTIN, LET'S GO BACK TO MY
APARTMENT.
YOU CAN ALL TAKE ONE THING HOME
WITH YOU.
>> YEA
>> THANK YOU, STEVE.
>> ONE THING.
>> AWESOME
♪ NOW I'M ALL ATO LOAN
>> YOU TALK CRAP ABOUT MY
DAUGHTER, YOU'RE DEAD.
>> A HAD, H!